hello everyone and welcome to the last
big tournament of the year it is
defeated World rapid and Blitz
Championship first we are having three
days of rapid and then two days of Blitz
and this is a game from round one uh
Samuel Teresa can versus Magnus Carlsen
uh Abdul Satur of neuterbeck will be
defending his title as the world rapid
champion and Magnus uh of course is
playing as the highest rated player uh
mostly I will cover magnus's games if
they're not going to be a snooze snooze
Fest about you guys of course do use
hashtag suggestion and I will try to
cover as many games as possible as there
are so many games being played there are
like uh home I think almost 180 players
uh playing this so and many many
ingredients will be played uh so many uh
fighting games are happening it's I mean
the the bar is just going left and right
it's absolutely crazy it's being played
in Kazakhstan in Alma team and it will
be played the the rapid section from
26th to 28th of December price fund is
350 000 and first prize for winning the
world rapid champion chip is sixty
thousand dollars players will have 15
minutes um for the entire game plus 10
seconds increments starting from move
one so it's a rapid format of course as
it's the world rapid Championship uh and
uh if there is a tie for first place
players will go into a playoff they will
play Blitz Games three plus two and if
those uh end in a draw uh there will not
be Armageddon but they will continue
playing three plus two uh until one
player wins so uh sort of a different
than what we're used to but uh uh you
know the the world champion will not be
decided by an Armageddon game this time
so let's check it out it's quite a game
uh somewhere with the white pieces opens
with uh Ponte E4 and like in the
previous game that we've shown uh we
have the French defense Ponte E6 so
let's see what Magnus prepared for this
uh a very strong event D4 D5 we have
Knight the C3 and the Magnus goes for
the winner variation with Bishop to B4
which is a very very
uh uh crazy stuff right from the from
the opening E5 and now Pawn to C5 so
this is all a very very main
um uh stuff uh A3 attacks the bishop
Bishop captures and c3b captures and now
three moves are the most popular here 97
Queen C7 and queen A5 but Magnus goes
for uh Knight the C6 which is sort of
the fourth the fourth most popular move
but still I considered very much main
Theory Queen G4 going after the G7 pawn
and the G6 and of course Samuel strikes
with H4 yeah he wants to play H5 and
open up his Rook uh and the problem is
if you block this with H5 as black
usually does then Queen F4 and it's very
very annoying to play this for Black
Knight is coming to F3 to G5 and so on
so uh there uh are some options you
could play here Magnus goes for Queen to
A5 he puts pressure on the C3 pawn and
now Bishop to D2 defending and there are
a couple of moves that were played in
this position Queen A4 is always a very
popular preventing White from I'm
playing A4 and putting pressure on that
C2 Pawn also Knight the H6 has been
attempted here sort of an idea of Bishop
captures then you can capture on C3 but
it's actually a very bad move after
Queen G5 that Knight is just looking
very silly H5 is coming and the black
will fall apart very quickly so Magnus
instead goes H6 and it is now as of move
9 that we have a completely new game
so white goes A4 always a good move
taking away that A4 Square from the
White Queen and now Pawn to C4 Magnus
closes the queen side and he will now
Focus all the attention on the uh on the
on the king side where he can execute F6
or F5 at some point then it should be
very good for him Knight to F3 the
Knight does not have access to G5 so
more often than not we will see Queen F4
Knight H2 Knight to G4 and the Knight
will have access to the F6 Square Bishop
to D7 Magnus prepares the castle Queen
side and now uh the immediate Queen F4
preventing castles as the F7 Pawn is
hanging so uh Rook to H7 now the F7 Pawn
is defended and Magnus is ready to
Castle Knight H2 the Knight begins his
maneuver Queen side Castles by Magnus
and now Knight to G4 putting pressure on
that F6 Square Rook to f8 preparing to
execute F5 or F6 depending on what white
plays and now Bishop to E2 we have Queen
back to d8 the queen no longer has as a
purpose on A5 and now you could consider
Knight to F6 and maybe you even should
for example Knight F6 you trade
everything and it's a very nice position
for white black will have trouble with
this F6 Pawn the Rooks are completely
blocked in it's a light Square Bishop so
you can't reach the dark Square pawn and
the Knight will need uh well quite a few
squares to reach that pawn for the
moment it's impossible to reach the pawn
so white will have a firm grip on the
position so uh it's it's definitely a
possibility but in the game we have
Queen to G3
uh and now comes Pawn to F5 Magnus does
not miss this opportunity to to prevent
Knight to F6 we have e captures and F6
Alpha saw Knight captures and F6 but uh
this uh uh breaking of the position uh
sort of in magnus's favor comes at the
price of a pawn and of course somewell
grabs it Bishop captures on H6 and this
is where the fun really starts so The
Rook is hanging and you would be of
course very happy if you could capture
the Knight and then capture the bishop
but the Rook is hanging so here uh after
Bishop captures in H6 we have Knight the
E4 Magnus attacks the queen on G3 Queen
to E3 you are now defending the bishop
twice and now Rook after h8 and okay
you're down upon but you have this
immense pressure on the H file and uh
here best way for white to play this
would be Pawn to F3 but it's rapid of
course you can't invest all that much
time on every move point is that after
Knight G3 you will play Bishop G5 attack
the black queen and after Queen A5 you
have this madness of a position where
it's impossible to evaluate is just you
know the better player wins in this
position so here Bishop to F3 was played
instead of F3 and this gives Magnus
enough time to execute a central
breakthrough and he plays Pawn to E5
which is great as the white king is
still on E1 and okay D captures an E5
and now Magnus goes Queen to A5 uh going
for that C3 Pawn I will just show uh as
it's a very nice line uh how Magnus
could have just won the game on the spot
uh he could have played Bishop captures
on G4 which is weird because you allow
the recapture with check but after
Bishop characters and King to B8 uh your
Bishop on H6 is hanging so you have to
move it you can't move it to G5 because
then we just capture capture and The
Rook on each one would be hanging so you
would have to go to F4 and now just Rook
captures an H4 and the White's position
is terrible here for example captures
captures uh the bishop is hanging Rook
to H1 is coming and there's really not a
good move here if you try some like E6
with check just King the a 8 and if you
try Bishop to E2 to block Rook the H1
with Bishop to F1 uh it doesn't really
matter now you're gonna play G5 and
after the G3 Queen A5 and the white will
not be able to withstand all this
pressure so that's one way to do it but
in the game Magnus played Queen to A5 of
course all of those ideas are still in
the position he just started with a
different move order uh and now uh White
should counter this with King to F1 he
should disregard the death of the C3
Pawn is hanging he should play King F1
and now if Magnus were to actually
captured upon with Knight captures on C3
or with Queen captures and C3 uh there
are big problems here just Queen
captures Knight captures and now let's
say Dash up to G5 and it's not uh not
not a great position for black black
doesn't really have anything for the
pawn bishop G5 now defends the H4 pawn
and it's uh perfectly fine and uh of
course yeah after King F1 if you
actually go for Knight captures on C3
then you have this E6 move and that is
just a very nasty stuff and now you
don't really have a good way of dealing
with this uh like if you you can capture
a pawn but let's say you move it uh now
comes Bishop to G5 everything is nicely
defended and you don't really have a
threat that Knight on C3 isn't really
doing all that much so uh something to
consider but as Samuel was very low on
time he played Rook to A3 defended upon
this way and now Bishop to F5 Magnus
gets the bishop into the game now G3
defending the H4 Pawn also could be the
way to do it but here some will castle
kingside and this is a recipe for
disaster with the Rooks double and the H
file and Magnus does not miss an
opportunity to to go for the win here
problem is you can't capture right away
you would love to capture capture and
then just eliminate the bishop but
Bishop will capture with checks so
Magnus starts with King to B8 it is the
absolute strongest move by the engine uh
and now Bishop to G5 defending the H4
Pawn but I mean not really just Knight
captures and G5 Queen captors and The
Rook captures on H3 threatening Rook to
H1 Checkmate and here somehow plays G3
so uh what's uh what's Happening Here
can Magnus win this game or not feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the absolute strongest move for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you
um uh who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting a very very
difficult line and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
the H5 this is the only move that wins
the game uh problem is that next move we
are capturing the night and there's no
good way to recapture let's see Queen F4
uh now you just play Bishop captures on
G4 and the light Square Bishop cannot
capture because uh White will just get
destroyed with Rook to H1 and if Queen
captures then Knight captures on E5
attacks the queen and the bishop and now
you have to defend the bishop somehow
there are no good squares for that if
you go Rook therefore then Rook F5 uh
and that's it you will either suffer
severe material loss or even if you move
the queen you will get checkmated for
example King G2 Rook to H2 will be
Checkmate so that was the way to do it
however Magnus played Rook captures and
G4 it's the second top move recommended
by the engine but it does give black
some chances Bishop captures on G4 and
now Bishop to E4 which looks weird
because white can just play F3 obviously
and stop Checkmate but that's exactly
what Magnus wants assemble to do and
this whole idea Works due to the poor
placement of The Rock and A3 so after F3
is played you have to play this
otherwise you're lost and now Queen to
C5 check picks up the rook and A3 very
very cool stuff King to G2 and now Queen
capture 783 and now the queen side pawns
will fall as well uh White has to
recapture we have Queen captures on C3
and now even e captures and D5 grabbing
that pawn but this allows Magnus to uh
just play very very precise chess now if
you play Knight captures an E5 then it's
not the most precise way you will just
go Dash up to E2 now the queen cannot
capture because the Knight hangs and if
you play Rook d8 to defend the Knight
then just Bishop to D1 defends the pawn
and it looks ugly for white but white
will uh probably hold this yeah so after
he captures on D5 Magnus plays the
strongest Queen captures in C2 check
Rook to F2 and now again only one way to
win this game for Magnus and he finds it
Queen to B1 uh threatening Queen to H1
Checkmate I say he finds it but he
doesn't really find it as uh he doesn't
proceed in the most precise way possible
but someone was extremely low on time
here so Magnus did not want to invest
any extra time giving some well uh well
the comfort of of calculating on
magnus's time so Rook to F1 and here you
have to play Queen to B2 check Queen B2
check Rook F2 and now Queen captures on
E5 uh threatening to capture the queen
and of course if you just trade
everything uh the the end game is
completely winning for black but in the
game Magnus played Queen to E4 with
check Bishop to F3 and now Queen
captures an E5 now it's a bit easier to
defend this now Queen captures on G6
still threatening to win the Knight
Knight the D4 and now we have Queen to e
for offering the queen trade Magnus
trades here a queen captures an E4
Bishop captures and Rook the E8 now and
uh now it's uh it's pretty much an equal
end game material is equal Bishop
against tonight but some will extremely
low on time below the one minute Mark
way below the one minute Mark and Magnus
uh comfortably I believe over over five
minutes so these six was played here uh
with King to C8 uh of course you need
the king to stop this past Pawn at some
point and also King is very important in
the end game and now you have to play
Rook death for pretty much the only move
that guarantees a draw for white uh
putting pressure on the Knight putting
pressure on the pawn here and at some
point you will win the C4 Pawn but in
the game Bishop to D5 was played right
away and this just threatens nothing it
does have the immediate threat of Bishop
captures and C4 but it's not your move
Magnus just plays C3 and that's it Rook
to F7 was played going after uh the pawn
also D7 check is being threatened but
now Rook to E2 with check King to H3 and
pawn to C2 and there is no good way to
to do anything here you don't have time
for D7 check you will not be able to
promote on so Rook the C7 check was
played and now Magnus goes King to d8 uh
just to give you an example if he goes
King to B8 then it's a draw white will
just move the rook and Advance the pawn
and that's enough for a draw you don't
have time for Rook D1 Rook to C1 but
Magnus just played Rook a king to d8 and
he was in this position on move 42 that
uh Samuel tersachyan resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
there is no counter play uh denied that
defends the pawn so next move we're just
gonna play rookie one and C1 and that's
it you don't have a way of putting
pressure on that pawn in any way and
that's just it D7 does nothing like you
move the Rook now I mean it's pointless
King V7 will pick up the pawn and that's
it so pretty crazy game uh as it as it
usually is in the in the winner
variation of the French Magnus comes up
on top but as you as you've seen it was
not a one-sided game not at all uh but I
mean so many uh so many turnarounds in
this uh rapid format and I believe we
can expect all the games to be like this
uh sure that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed this first game we are showing
of the video World rapid Championship uh
do use hashtag hashtag suggestion and as
I will check out all of your suggestions
I imagine there will be some spectacular
games played here uh so thank you all um
uh for for joining in uh I would like to
thank uh Ricky black uh Lars Oliver uh
groundhog uh Jeff Graves David Rice
Oxley and David Kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing uh the coverage
of the video rapid World rapid
Championship uh until it finishes uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day